in 2002 the dictator of Venezuela Hugo  Chavez announced that he was planning on  selling oil in Euros instead of the  mighty US dollar Venezuela happens to  have the largest oil reserves in the  world well we can't have that now can we  so in 2002 the U.S backed a coup against  Chavez which ultimately failed but it  crippled the country and its economy  Empires are built on oil yet despite  having the largest oil reserves in the  world today Venezuela is one of the  poorest economies in the world because  it's by Design the entire strategy of  the US has always been to financially  enslaved countries to siphon all their  wealth and if you want to gain power you  better take a page out of their book  which is why I expose all of this in my  new course Financial slavery Master  Class watched the first lesson for free  with the link in the pinned comment and  make around a hundred dollars for every  person you refer to it